today's assignment we're going to take
out this vehicle so city streets are
tested out to see how it responds to the
city traffic for the first thing we want
to have this just legroom Headroom the
ability to maneuver inside the vehicle
have our controls all available to us
with hand-eye coordination not happen to
be a big issue so now we're going to
step on inside and see how this handles
autumn Ortiz here we go
the view officer hard
great crowds come upon to stay here in
San Diego
well we're gonna need something probably
a little slimmer than this guy I don't
think he's gonna be able to handle about
140 miles an hour we're gonna use him
just mainly on city streets what I'm
rush I got to read Miranda write this
check out the wired channel the scene
calm for the entire giant creature
series